[Music]
hello and welcome to tonight's episode
of beginner breakdown my name is Alex
mulling and uh the topic I have for you
tonight is how to learn a chess opening
so in the past I've talked about you
know kind of how to make an opening
selection you know thinking of different
openings and what might fit you the best
and that we based it off considerations
of style and whether it's like a setup
based opening or a sequence based
opening feel free to check out that
video tonight we're not going to be
talking specifically about you know
finding the best opening for you but
it's more about when you found your
opening whatever you want to learn how
to actually go about learning it and
there's a few different things you want
to keep in mind we're going to be
talking about one there is still some
factor of you know your selection and um
understanding like what your approach is
because certain openings might allow for
different game plans um certain openings
might have different skill levels as
well um but the main thing we're going
to be thinking about are the goals the
plans the principles the style of the
opening as well as what resources you
can use to improve so whether that's
using just the internet and a web
browser books Lee chess or chess.com um
coaches videos Etc so without further
Ado let's kind of jump into it and I'm
going to give you the premise for this
video which was something that I do a
lot is I play a lot of bullet chess this
is bullet is one minute very very fast
there's some other VAR variant of the
time control but I play usually 1 minute
very fast and that's just because I am
maybe a little psychotic in that way um
and it's just a quick time thing I don't
mind if I lose a bullet game and most of
the time when you're playing the black
pieces in bullet like nine out of 10
times your opponent plays E4 happens so
often and against E4 I have a kind of
special bullet repertoire that I play I
don't play it normally cuz it's not very
good but it's kind of tricky so I play
some some Sicilian stuff and my ideas
are I like to get my queen and Bishop
out on this diagonal and put pressure on
F2 and it's very suspicious and not good
at all but very fun to play the problem
comes is that in bullet you don't have a
lot of time and so I'm pre-moving a
bunch and often on the first move
sometimes I'll just get impatient and
I'll pre-move C5 and sometimes my
opponent will play
D4 and now C5 is a little bit strange um
we're no longer playing a sicilian this
is something totally
different so from this position you know
I'm in whole new territory this isn't
something I'd studied it's just okay
well I guess I'm here I'm just playing a
game of chess but there's a lot to think
about right um sometimes people push
past my Pawn sometimes they take
sometimes they defend with a move like
Knight to F3 or C3 or E3 or something
and defend their Pawn there's a whole
bunch of different things that can
happen here but regardless of what my
opponent chooses to play I am to totally
out of
theory it's a funny message um okay so
there's a few options I have here one is
I could be a little more patient I could
sit on my hands right and try and make
the best move uh I could watch for my
opponent and be aware of the threats
they're making and do all of that
thinking and solid
playing or the other option is to be
real stubborn and stick with this move
and decide I'm gonna base a whole
YouTube video off learning a new opening
and that's what we're going to do so I
wouldn't necessarily recommend my
reasoning but I I do think we're going
to find something useful because in
thinking okay well I want to learn more
about this um I came to some really
interesting insights that I wanted to
share with you all so uh the first thing
is I took a look at my own kind of
Records in the database I just used
opening tree.com to give me insight into
my own chess playing data and found that
yeah whenever my opponent plays D4 I've
played C5 way more often than I have
played my normal move which would be
Knight to F6 I've played C5 about like
540 times and I've played Knight to F6
about 420 times so I'm doing this one
way more and so yeah let's just kind of
jump into it first question is what is
this opening is it even an opening and
to answer that question right sometimes
you might be like oh I've heard about
some opening like the Spanish defense or
the alakim defense or the scotch game
you'll hear something be like that
sounds interesting or maybe I know
someone who plays that I want to try and
learn that in this case it's kind of the
opposite I have some moves on a board
and I don't know what it's called so how
am I going to find out well what I did
is I just went uh into Lee chess uh
there was a really useful tool I just
went to the analysis board and plugged
in these moves and it told me right away
after I played D4 C5 it said I'm playing
the old bonon defense and it had a whole
quote it said the old Bon defense is
quite rare and uncommon nowadays but can
actually lead to a tactical and sharp
game uh black takes a swipe with C5 and
gambits a pawn for the exchange develops
get pieces into the game white normally
responds with D5 taking pawns and it
kind of goes into this whole long quote
I'm not going to read the whole thing
you can feel free to pull up a Le chest
browser and see what it says um but that
is already giv me a lot of information I
have a name old the non defense I can
now use that to look it up and get some
more information um and it has the
information it just gave me so let's
actually break down kind of what was in
that quote and how I can use that to try
and learn this as a new
opening okay first of all I want to
understand the real Basics and for those
who aren't aware of like any opening
principles so the three opening
principles as always you want to control
the center of the board um controlling
this space is very helpful it's going to
be a great launching pad for your army
wherever you need to Target right if
you're trying to Target your opponent's
king if they stay in the center you want
your pieces to stay in the center if
they switch to the king side you want to
be able to switch your pieces quickly to
the king side and vice versa for the
queen side right and moving your pieces
from the center to that direction is
easier than moving it from one side of
the board to the other so we want to
control the center of the board we want
to develop our pieces right if they're
just sitting on the back row not doing
anything that's not super helpful and
finally we want to worry about King
safety how is our King safe how are we
making our opponent's king unsafe so
we're keeping those questions in mind
with everything we do now E4 is a much
sharper more tactical game most of the
time right the bishop and the queen are
coming out sometimes there's threats
against F7 and we've seen all of this
stuff before
D4 is a more strategic positional game
right um it's more about denying your
opponent right so D4 is stopping white
or sorry stopping Black from doing a few
things I can't play E5 anymore because
I'm just going to get taken I mean I can
it's a Gambit I think it's called the
England Gambit not objectively very good
but kind of tricky um but yeah I don't
just want to give up a pawn here and
Knight to C6 another move I like to play
in a lot of variations is maybe not so
good here either because you know maybe
the pawn can just push forward and
provoke my knight so this move is more
about denying black opportunities than
making stuff for white right you know
white can get this bishop out but that's
really the only thing they've helped
with development with
D4 so what's the point with C5 well the
first part of that quote from Lee chess
was black takes a swipe with C5 and
gambits a pawn for the exchange so a
Gambit is just anytime we're giving up
material for some kind of compensation
some other benefit in this case the idea
is we're gambiing it for what gambits a
pawn for the exchange develops and gets
a piece into the game uh get pieces into
the game so I'm trying to get my pieces
into the game be very active and trying
and control a lot of space and make
threats uh in exchange for giving up
this
Pawn what Knight normally responds with
D5 and this is interesting to me right
the first time I look at this I see well
wait a minute there's a very natural
move which is just for the pawn to
recapture so in my mind I need to think
about this but then if I go back to that
Lee chest quote it actually tells me
something about it says taking the pawn
is not recommended because of
E6 and now we see there is a discovered
attack this bishop has opened up and is
attacking
C5 and it and if white tries defending
this Pawn right something like
B4 then black can continue
A5 and white has no solutions to keep
holding on to these pawns and you might
not see that at first you're like well
wait a minute they have other pawns they
can defend well the problem is we just
have too much pressure our Bishop is
kind of x-raying through this Pawn if
you try something like A3 this isn't
very good because notice the Rooks are
now kind of lined up up if I take you
can't actually take back or you're going
to lose your Rook so you can't play
A3 C3 looks like a more reasonable try
right now if I take and you take back
then I still can't take with my Bishop
so what might be the point here well I
can take and if you take back I can just
continue development with a really nice
attack with something like Queen to
F6 and notice your Rook is not defended
by any thing it's kind of stuck in the
corner and it's
actually I think impossible to save you
can sacrifice something else there give
up well the knight's maybe not good yeah
it's actually very hard to save this
piece and you can try and explore that
on your own what you might try but this
is not a very good way to play for for
white and so this is you know I'm
already learning okay so there's some
traps here in this opening right this is
kind of tricky line and if you know if
white just plays normal moves here I
don't know something like Knight C 3
then I feel very good in this position
I've developed my Bishop my pawns are
kind of really nicely guarding these
light squares I can try and play for a
kingside castle I can push for D5 I have
some options my only concern in this
type of position might be that my Bishop
is not very developed I'm you know it's
going to be hard to get it out this way
so I'm probably going to need to get it
out this way but as long as I keep that
in mind and think about how I'm going to
develop that piece this feels pretty
comfortable to try and play so okay I'm
not really worried worried about that
capture anymore and again the that's all
because of what leech has told me but D5
is the main move the other thing I want
to look at is right what if they defend
right well it's already defended by the
queen so they could just ignore it and
play some move but then you run into
some problems almost like a reverse
Scandinavian where if the queen comes
out I can just kind of attack it and get
some free development it's going to have
to waste time it came out it's going to
have to waste time running away and I've
gotten just free moves with my pieces uh
I actually don't mind that the C Pawn is
gone cuz my queen can maybe come out
somewhere on this diagonal later and
cause some trouble so this feels fine to
play as well I wouldn't be worried about
memorizing the theory from
here uh and if you just defend it with
something else you know whatever else a
knight a pawn then I'm probably still
just going to take and you know I've
gotten rid of a center Pawn for white
for one of my side
white has a little bit more Center
control but white also got the first
move so I can't be too upset about that
um and so these are just my initial
thoughts right I know nothing about this
opening other than what I've been kind
of breaking down with you and like I had
heard the name bonon defense I knew the
real Basics but this was all stuff I was
investigating today and the point isn't
for you to take an understanding about
the bonon defense you're free to but I'm
not an expert in that what I'm trying to
share with you you is how I went about
learning this opening what I did to try
and find it so I just kind of
experimented around and played around
with some different moves I used the
engine to see like what it was
recommending as well as what leest was
automatically telling me from that quote
okay so D5 is the main move the most
popular move and it's the one I need to
work on the other thing that I noticed
immediately without getting too far off
track is is remember something that Lee
chess said about this opening it said
this opening is quite rare nowadays one
IDE is for black to transpose to a
modern
bonon okay well and then you think well
this was called the old bonon defense so
I guess maybe there is a more modernized
version and so I just Googled modern
bonon and old bononi and found that the
modern Bon defense I just found this
from like a Wikipedia page uh is a chess
opening that begins with the moves 1 D4
two Knight f
six uh White plays 2 C4 C5 so we've
started with the Knight and then pushed
the pawn and then usually white
continues with D5 and black with E6 and
this is kind of the modern bonon
position and so okay well we can
transpose to this from the old bonon so
if I play C5 and if white continues with
D5 I attack with my knight and and if
you play C4 to defend well now we're
just in that exact same position so I've
learned okay so there's an old version
and a new version and the one I've been
playing is the old version is there any
reason why it's old for this um it's
sometimes harder to find some of those
more noodly questions I had the luxury
of working here at the chess club and so
I just asked some of my co-workers who
are more experienced in this opening um
you know why one is the old one what's
not so modernized about it you might
also be able to find this from some
online videos or books but um the main
reason as far as I understand it is that
the problem is after C5
D5 if I continue with Knight to F6 then
white does not have to play Pawn to C4
they can play something like Knight to
C3 instead defending and now white can
shoot for just more General control of
center with something like Pawn to E4
and maybe this Knight eventually kind of
travels over to C4 where that pawn was
um and this is maybe a little harder for
me to deal with just the space advantage
that my opponent has so this is kind of
a more highlevel reason why the old
version has been more modernized is that
relevant for me well maybe but I
actually am not so convinced it is I
think it's good to know about but that
shouldn't be a deterrent for me playing
the old version for a few reasons one
I'm not looking to play a lot of grand
masters with this opening and not in
fast time controls or in slow time
controls this is more of a trick weapon
and something I just want to try and
learn and understand and see how it
works um and so I'm not worried about my
opponent knowing like the perfect modern
Theory to punish my opening so that's
kind of my first
thought okay um let's the other thing to
know is yeah this opening the modern one
so not just the old version but starting
with Knight to
F6 um this is a much more theoretical
opening which just means that it's been
studied a lot more by Grand Masters by
chess engines and so there's a lot more
data on what moves are more accurate and
less accurate and more people who are
going to be memorizing book moves about
it than with C5 so that's actually for
me a reason I maybe want to stick with
the older one because not many people
are going to be as familiar with it and
it's going to be a better surprise
weapon so I've been mentioning kind of
these databases that I've been using to
like engines and different things and
there's some really interesting
information you can learn so on Lee
chess for example there's you could also
use chess base or there's plenty of
different ways to get access to a chess
database but Le chess is is just free
and it's online and I went to it and
there's a few different settings you can
just go to the Master's database which
Imports a whole bunch of Master games
high level games um and you can go to
the leest database and the leest
database just takes everybody who's
played on their servers and takes those
games and just automatically uploads
them to the database I I
believe and so there was a few different
things of information I got the first
was I went to the Master's database and
I noticed that D4 C5 D5 in the Master's
database this is what happens anytime
somebody plays
C5 70% or sorry 76% of games in the
Master's database in this position white
wins okay so White's winning 75% of the
time black winning about 25% of the time
and very few draws so that tells me a
lot one this is just probably better for
white right if Masters are winning three
quarters of the time here with white
that's better but also it's a very
imbalanced game right not a lot of draws
so you're going to have some sharp
exciting stuff so that's good to know
about the
opening um and I also saw that these
were the moves played the vast majority
of the time everything other than D5 uh
was played less than 10% of the time so
really D5 is the main thing I need to
learn if I want to theoretically know
how to beat this
opening I still want to learn the other
ones and so my approach to that is well
if I know what's the main line I also
want to think about what are the popular
things that are getting played and to do
that I just put some filters on the
leest database I went to the leest
database I clicked it I put uh and if
you can't see that's okay I'll describe
it but uh oh cool um so you can see down
here these are all the different moves
and the it's says the
percentages and it's got the old bonon
defense written here so that's really
useful um and I went into this kind of
filter and uh this is the one it's set
to now I'm not going to mess with this
because this is just the same L test
clubs one but um I set it to all the
faster time controls basically anything
that was faster than classical or
correspondence so rapid Blitz bullet
Ultra bullet and then for the rating I
put it from 400 up to 1,800 and I took
off 2, 2200 2500 and my reasoning was
well that's about my skill level I am a
1500 USCF player give on a good day um
and I'm mostly playing these faster
times so those are the moves that I want
to look at what are people playing at my
skill level at my time control and when
I put those filters on the data I got
was uh that one it's about a 5050 split
between white and black winning so the
people at my level aren't uh versed
enough in this opening Theory to know
how white is supposed to get their
advantage at least not as much as the
Masters are um and two while D5 is still
the most popular number to move uh it
was only played about 23% of the time
compare that with the 76% of the time it
was played by the Masters uh the other
moves D take C5 was played about as much
it was about 20% C4 about 16% and then a
bunch of moves defending the pawn E3 C3
Knight F3 were played in total about 30
% between all all of those three
moves which told me that okay I'm going
to be faced with a whole bunch so if I
want to look at this opening I should
probably know the most critical Mainline
stuff but I don't need to spend all my
energy there I can spend a good amount
of time and I should understanding what
to do if they play a whole bunch of
different
stuff okay so this is still kind of my
preparation I haven't actually learned
really any of the plans in this opening
yet uh I'm still just finding some
information about it to get comfortable
with how to then learn learn more about
it um the other things I want to mention
some just really quick other books and
online resources I found a few um
there's on Wiki books I found some
information about this opening the old
Bon the problem was it gave me more
generalized stuff lots of the variations
and the you know really really Mainline
and traditional ideas but it didn't give
like detailed breakdowns and how to
punish mistakes so if you want to get
comfortable with information a book
something like that can usually give you
some more generalized approach but more
specific books so I found in our our
library um for example there was one
called the complete bononi by Lev sakis
uh It Was Written In 1995 which is a
little old for an opening book cuz you
know engines have really improved the
lines a lot but to just familiarize
myself with opening plans that felt like
a good one to look for and then also
there were some online videos some that
the trest club has put out by uh
Jonathan Tron did a few called modern
bononi is no balone those are pretty fun
if you want to learn about this opening
particularly
um yaser San our spokesperson put out a
video called a road map within the
modern bononi those are again the modern
not the old one but just YouTube looking
up different videos you can look up from
us or from other channels there's plenty
of great ones out there um had good
information so those are some other
resources you can use and now I want to
talk about a little more specifics of
this opening so the first place I went
was I went to some of those videos there
was one by national Master Jim mlin here
at the chess club and he
uh talked about this idea that C5 the
problem he says with the old Boni here
is that it's conceding a space advantage
and this is what helped me understand
well why is D5 played so much why is it
so good and he said well it's giving
white a pawn that's way strong in my
territory right normally that's doesn't
happen in something like D4 D5 right a
more classical game I'm holding off
White's advance or even you know
something like the nimzo right anything
that's stopping white from just
immediately pressing forward uh is
important and so the downside there is I
have given white some more space and
especially once they've played C4 and
try and really locked in that space I'm
going to be a little more cramped right
notice right away it's harder for me to
develop some of my pieces this night
it's not so easy to get into the game
this way one of the Bishops is going to
be kind of stuck right E6 or D6 I'm
going to play one of those moves to
fight against this pawn and the bishop
that's stuck behind is going to have a
little bit of trouble right if I play E6
for example this bishop has a little bit
of trouble and vice
versa so I have some space and
development problems I need to kind of
face here in compensation he argues is
well one thing you can do is lock up the
position so he showed an example of D6
and if white plays something like C4 you
can continue with
E5 and notice here this position is very
blockaded so the the nice thing is it's
not uh easy to get checkmated very
quickly here right um there's not many
open lines for the Bishops the Rooks the
Queens the heavy pieces to infiltrate
the position it's going to be a more
slow maneuvering game and you know if
that's your style maybe that'll help you
that's not exactly how I wanted to play
the system so I thought okay well that
gave me some information but let's see
what else I can find and so I went back
to that book The Complete Bon by Lev
sakis and went and found something
interesting so uh his stuff was all
recommending the modern Bon but remember
some of those transpositions can happen
right if uh so this is the old one and
we can transpose to the modern in this
move order again white has to choose to
play C4 they don't have to but if they
do then all of the theory he was writing
about still
applies and from this position I did uh
something that I'm going to recommend to
people is if you have an access to a
book or something often there will be an
index of variations either in the front
with like the table of contents or
somewhere in the back and this was in
the back of his book and what I did is I
went to those leest database numbers and
I followed what are the most popular
moves that my opponents are playing at
my level at the speed of game I'm
playing and what moves would this book
recommend against them and so I I looked
and this is what I found so in this
position the most popular move that
white would play against someone of my
skill level uh and at the speed I'm
playing is Knight to C3 which is I think
the main line and his recommendation was
e takes D5 C takes D5 was the most
popular
D6
E4 G6 and I thought okay well so maybe
this is now telling me this is kind of a
fian ketto style opening where I want to
fian ketto my bishop and I can already
start to see maybe why that is right I
have my pawns occupying these dark
squares initially the one on C5
controlling these dark squares and so
now getting my Bishop right it's not
going to come out this way probably so
getting it you know to
G6 and then kind of eyeing this long
diagonal looks like a very powerful tool
right it's really helping me sub met my
control of the center so I was like okay
well that makes sense Knight to F3 most
popular move uh from my settings Bishop
to
G7 something else I was noticing as I
was going here is I was tracking is the
most popular move the same as the most
critical move the one that the Masters
are playing in their database and so far
they have been this is where that
diverges the main moves by far in the
leeches database uh are Bishop E2 Bishop
D3
H3 uh Bishop
G5 in the Master's database Bishop B2
and H6 are the winners by far and the
most popular move in the leeches datab
base was Bishop to
D3 and so I was in this index and I
thought okay so I need to look at some
of those other moves and figure out why
I can start to maybe Inuit it why some
of them are good right Bishop G5 pinning
the Knight H3 probably preventing Bishop
to G4 you know maybe they don't want to
let me get this pin Bishop E2 I didn't
really understand why is this the main
move why is this more popular than
Bishop D3 this looks more natural maybe
I'm controlling this
diagonal um so I explored I thought okay
well if Bishop D3 is played then castles
is the move recommended Bishop G4 is
another line um but this there was a few
lines that were kind of offered here and
this maybe shows the age of the book a
little bit the computer kind of actually
liked some of the things that he wasn't
so sure about and again that's because
what 20 30 years have passed since he
wrote it and technology has advanced
quite a bit um but something like this
might happen or say Bishop
G4 the reason he didn't like this move
was only it wasn't because of H3 or
anything else it was only because of
Queen to
A4 if I block the Knight to
D2 and I thought well that's really
interesting the whole point of this
check was just so I don't trade with the
Knight the Knight runs away and it's
going to go maybe here or I'm not sure
so that was kind of
interesting and then I went to the
bishop E2 lines and saw well wait a
minute if this is played after Bishop G4
white does the same thing so now I've
learned okay white really wants to keep
this Knight on the board they they don't
mind trading the Bishops or anything but
they don't want to let this Knight get
taken off and I still have to figure out
some of why that is um I I think looking
at it right now this Square looks kind
of nice to attack this backwards D6 Pawn
um and maybe also once the Bishops are
traded maybe the Knight even can go back
to L F3 and help fight for this E5
square right right a few different kind
of ideas potentially again I'm not an
expert in this don't trust me on benon
knowledge but in learning how do I gain
information about a new opening and
learn it for myself I think this is kind
of helpful um okay the next thing I did
was I looked at some master games and
these some of these came from books some
of these came from YouTube um just
looking up old Bon defense Master games
and there were a few interesting ones
that came up the first one I want to
show here
uh is a game that was played between uh
someone named salaman and with the black
pieces was Bobby fiser and then thinking
oh that's cool Bobby fiser played this
opening I found out that well he and
another player who I really like male
tall both played this opening which is
telling me this can really be played for
some very sharp exciting chess which is
something I kind of like to hear that's
something I'm interested in D4 uh now in
the game it was the modern way right
Knight to F6 C5 and E6 if we had played
the old Boni C5 immediately assuming
white still kind of gives us some move
order to get here we're going to
transpose into the same thing but either
way uh the position reaches this and
we're not going to go through the whole
game just kind of the intro to something
that I found really helpful uh and this
I actually want to shout out uh uh aod
M's chess Channel because the video that
I found this from was from called when
fiser plays Bon you run really it was
it's a really good video I recommend you
check it out and there's something he
said very early on in like the first two
or three minutes and that's really the
only thing I'm going to talk about to
let people go over to him too was he
kind of played through the first couple
moves of this game so Knight to C3 Pawn
takes Pawn takes G6 D6 so this is
similar we saw all this in those
Mainline stuff and we can talk about
some of the specifics if we have time
but I want to focus on more just general
opening Theory and learning them Bishop
37 F4 and so another really critical
idea that comes in a lot of this is this
Pawn loves to push because white would
love to continue taking space at some
point in the center with E5 and so what
a godm talked about that I thought was
really helpful here was in the game
white played Knight to F3 but he stopped
and he said but I used to play the
bononi a lot as
black again this is a good mon talking I
used to play the Black and I was really
afraid of my opponent playing
E5 and then he immediately broke down
why this wasn't a good idea and this is
I think so helpful for if you're looking
to learn a new opening is to find really
good YouTube channels that talk about
the opening and not just here's what you
should do but also well here's what
doesn't work whether it's for your side
or your opponents because the best way
to get that is from experience and
that's what they're sharing and so it
looks like E5 right away is really scary
right we can imagine takes takes and now
like our Knight has to move but look at
look at these pawns like that is so
scary and he said this is not something
to worry about at all and here's why
right he said the problem is after our
Knight
moves the bishop and Knight double
attack this E5 pawn and there's not a
good way to keep it safe black white is
actually going to lose one of these
pawns and maybe even both of them
because they're
overextended he gave this example well
what if you play E6 right getting out of
the line of fire and putting pressure
well okay let's take
recaptures and now Queen
H4 and we can see that we are punishing
white for being a little too aggressive
this is why you start with Knight to F3
instead of pushing E5 because this the
Knight one defends E5 an extra time and
it prevents this queen move and the
problem is now after something like G3
because you don't want to move the king
you're going to lose castling rights
after
G3 uh you can interpose we eventually
want to get the queen kind of in the
center and punishing this Rook which is
now exposed but the Knight guards the
square so there's a really nice
intermetzo instead of responding to our
Queen being attacked we take the Knight
with check you have to recapture and now
Queen to E4 is brutal um there's no time
to worry about taking this Knight if you
take it we can just take back and
there's no way to save this Rook if you
try and block with the Knight Rook takes
the bishop is pinned and white is in a
lot of trouble here so something like
that was extremely helpful to me as
someone coming in saying this is a new
opening I know very little about um and
he in breaking down this master game
says well here's something that I might
have been worried about and why you
shouldn't be I think that's incredible
right so finding people on YouTube who
can or or chess coaches people are more
familiar with these openings who can
talk to you about the dos and don'ts is
something incredibly incredibly
helpful uh another example of this came
from a different book uh 1 D4 the chess
Bible by International Master Armen
juhas um and he kind of this is
something that's kind of funny that I
like to do I don't know if other people
do but I would recommend it is if you're
trying to learn an opening is find
people who have written books talking
about how to beat it with the other
color right so in the 1 D4 chess Bible
this is someone saying if you're going
to play 1 D4 here's your repertoire
here's what you should know and so in
this book he talks about well what if
your opponent plays the bononi um I
think he spends again more time on the
modern bononi than on the old one but
again as long as we are only looking at
those transposition lines it's still
going to apply to a lot of the games I
play so some of the stuff he writes
about right because he's trying to tell
someone with the white pieces how to
defeat this he's going to show multiple
lines that the black can play and he's
also going to show mistakes that both
sides can make and so this is really
help for someone trying to learn a new
opening his explanation of the AL
Boni was and this is what he wrote alak
among other players played this move
order the advantage is it avoids some
Sidelines like the trompowsky and now
I'm like oh that makes sense so some
people don't want to play Knight F6
because now you have to worry about
other stuff right they play the
trompowsky is actually Bishop to G5 if
you didn't know that you could always
Google it um and now there's not really
time to play C5 because they're just
going to take your knight and life is
strange um so that's maybe one advantage
to this is I can avoid a lot of those
Sidelines but he writes the downside is
that white can decide to play without C4
so this is again what kind of my uh
cooworker was telling me is well you can
just play something like this and
eventually get Knight C3 without C4 and
you can play for E4 and white has an
incredibly strong Center without having
to commit to this C4 pawn and fall into
a lot of the normal lines so again
something to be aware of uh he also
commented on the space problem right
that white is really invading our space
and it's hard to keep everything safe so
that's another kind of noteworthy thing
I
found um okay I want to look at a couple
M it's three more games I think we'll
have time for all three two of them are
Master games and one of them is one of
my own um and again the point of a
master game isn't to say well here's all
the moves you need to play right if you
don't memorize these moves you're no
good maybe at a grandm super high level
you get to that point but I think it's
much more important to look at a master
game and say what are the plans you know
not just what positions did these guys
get to and what move orders but what
ideas were they trying to do right what
were they making happen and how cuz
that's what you can apply to your own
game you might not remember the move
order but you can remember a plan and
think of different ways to execute it so
here was a game between gids and Tall
again I said Mikel tall played this with
the black pieces this is a really nice
example comes from
1957 in the game we have D4 Knight F6 C4
C5 D5 E6 same transposition thing this
is the modern bonon but the old bononi
can get to these lines Knight to C3 Pawn
takes D5 Pawn takes D5
D6 Knight to F3 G6 again we generally
understand the basic ideas uh D6 is
played to defend this Pawn open up our
Bishop we play this one to get this
bishop into the game everything so far
makes sense E4 and this is I think still
the main line and now Bishop to G7 um
but this was still in the 1 D4 chess B
book and uh jhaz argues there that
actually you know A6 A4 Bishop G4 is a
very nice idea for black so is maybe
recommending against this line of play
for white which is really helpful for me
to know as a player with black that if
my opponent plays this here's what I
should do um so really ni nice and he
argues here this is so critical right CU
remember we were looking earlier at well
white doesn't want to trade this Knight
he kind of confirms that idea for me he
says the problem here the reason this is
good for black is because after trading
away this Knight black can play knight
from D7 to E5 more effectively and no
longer has to worry about this Knight
moving to C4 attacking my Pawn maybe
attacking all of these dark squares
generally so again giving me more
confirmation and more information
about what are the plans my opponent has
how do I fight against them right so
this is super useful for me okay back to
our game Bishop to G7 Bishop to E2 again
we know the idea here is now if Bishop
G4 the Knight is fine to run away and
can put pressure on my
position black castles White Castles
Rook to E8 you know gaining more control
of the E file Knight back to D2 so even
without being provoked by this bishop
already White still wants to do this
plan you know so this is good to know
and Knight to A6 and here uh the uh J
has commentates that this is a very
thematic maneuver okay so that tells me
this is something I should pay attention
to this is something that comes up a lot
in these types of games and he explains
black wants to play Knight to C7 to help
carry out the Thematic B5
plan okay so that gives me a whole bunch
of information one it shows me a way to
deal with this problem right the Knight
can't really develop naturally and
cleanly to C6 so it goes to A6 and then
to C7 where it can help the pawn be
defended on B5 which is also telling me
we want to push this Pawn to B5 that's
not something I think I actually
explicitly talked about so far but it's
really important to understand as soon
as we play C5 we're fighting for space
on the queen side of the board and so
looking for ways you know A6 or this
Knight A6 to C7 maneuver but once our
Knight's on C7 looking to push the pawn
forward and fight on the queen side is a
key plan in this opening that's really
important to know so Knight to A6 white
plays Rook to E1 Knight goes to C7 as
expected A4 and we can understand this
move now it looks a little weird maybe
at first but now we say well Black's
plan is to play B5 one day so white
wants to put as much pressure against
that move as possible so this is
something to look out for it's a good
move for and if they don't play it then
maybe we have the time to play
B5 B6 is played so kind of accepting
this is interesting T is accepting here
that A4 is effectively stopping our plan
at least for a while and sometimes
that's good to know too right when do we
switch gears and maybe this Bishop's
going to more calmly develop maybe it's
going to be a slower push but we're
going to play a more positional game
we'll have to
see white plays Queen to C2 defending
E4 and Knight Knight to G4 and uh the
commentator argues this is a more
ambitious move that kind of sistic
something T would like to do right more
aggressive the knight's in the king's
face um and he says that something just
like Rook to B8 with the Simple Plan of
A6 B5 is still very reasonable so that's
also good for me to know but Knight to
G4 and what's interesting is I didn't
see the idea here now tal is always a
fun one to watch um after
H3 just trying to drive the Knight away
T's whole point is now Knight takes F2
sacrificing the Knight kind of just out
of the blue um and we start to realize
okay white actually might be in trouble
because look at the pressure that we can
exert with our Bishops if our Queen gets
involved it's actually kind of scary you
can't really afford not to take this
Knight CU if you just like attack it
then I can I can still insist on
sacrificing it but now your king is just
dead in the water there's nothing around
to keep you safe so you can't really
afford to do that so in the game King
takes F2 and the point here isn't again
necessarily to study tactics you're
welcome to master games are a great
source for that but this is more just
understanding the opening plans Queen to
H4 the king went back to F1 uh if you
tried to block with G3 there's just a
lot of danger right we can invade with
the bishop and we're going to be taking
here defended by our Bishop it's just
very very scary so in the game King to
F1 Bishop to D4 threatening
Checkmate the Knight drops back to D1
defending and now Queen takes H3 a
really beautiful move um if you
recapture then the Bishops dominate
everything and it's Checkmate so that's
really nice in the game instead uh White
saw this threat and played Bishop to F3
but T was able to you know use enough of
this advantage to continue to press and
slowly but surely worked his way in
opening files sacrificing material where
he had
to but lining up his pieces to get them
involved and eventually the king is just
too exposed and Falls to T's sacrificial
attack this is a really beautiful plan I
think actually back in this position
white just resigns um if you had
taken then simply Queen takes and the
king is just
dead and if instead you go
here then there's this really nice move
Bishop to B3 because if the queen takes
again we can just take and
invade and if the queen
moves then Queen takes this is a really
nice line I found and a beautiful Opera
Checkmate again the point of that isn't
to you you're feel free to look at the
game it's a beautiful beautiful game
lots of nice tactics and attacking ideas
to study but what I'm interested in here
is the opening and I've learned a few
key things one I learned that we have
this really key idea one we would love
to trade this Knight for this bishop if
possible because we don't want it to
come over here to C4 and annoy my pawns
two I've learned that I would really
like to play B5 and fight on the queen
side and often to do that I'm going to
use my knight to A6 and then to C7 where
it
defends and I'm also just going to play
Move like A6 and Rook to B8 and that's
another plan and finally I saw that
there's actually some nice attacking
potential here right with the bishop uh
kind of pointing at the castle my
control of the dark squares with this
bishop uh really allowed T to do a lot
of damage very quickly um which is nice
to keep in mind in your own games as
well okay the next Master game I want to
take a look at is uh shishkov versus
bavis B oh boy uh berwich which
something like that I apologize for the
mispronunciation uh this was played more
recently in
1999 um and something similar right
we're going to see what we can learn
from this master game D4 Knight F6 C4 C5
D5 E6 back to our modern bononi position
and again we see a lot of the same
things happen white wants to bring this
Knight out we the point of E6 is to take
um the reason they're not pushing here
is because it's too far Advanced our
Bishop already attacks it we can attack
it with the queen so you have to just
accept that the pawn is going to get
traded here takes takes D6 we don't want
to get it let it push too far forward
when we're not ready for it so D6 to
support
everything E4 G6 same thing again H3 so
this time white is actively preventing
the Bishop from coming to G4 so this is
going to be helpful to see okay well
what do we do in that case where this
bishop is not really able to do that
Bishop to G7 Knight F3 castles Bishop to
D3 and this is actually helpful to me
too because remember I said well why was
this move not as popular in the original
reason right we said Bishop B2 is better
because the Knight doesn't want to get
traded well here Whit's already kind of
avoided that with H3 so they can afford
to move the bishop a little farther so
that's good to know too right you don't
have to you know double up on this idea
as long as the Knight is free to jump
around then life is good for
white A6 preparing for the normal kind
of B5 idea A4 annoying stopping it and
now white goes to D7 okay so this Knight
well it's harder to play for B5 so maybe
and the bishop wasn't really doing
anything so black just decides that this
Knight is that this bishop is okay to
sit for a little while and this Knight
now is maybe trying to control
E5 castles and Knight to E8 and this is
a really interesting move for me black
wants to play Knight to E5 and the point
here is white wants to recapture with
the
bishop so you don't want to play Knight
to E5 right away because then if takes
the pawn takes and notice that this Pawn
is actually in our own way right we
control this space really well but now
our Bishop is kind of sad right it's
blocked off so you don't really want to
do that so what black begins with Knight
to E8 so that you can play this move uh
White interrupts Bishop G5 now there's
no time for Knight to E5 we have to stop
it
and F6 was the move of choice here just
moving a knight back doesn't really seem
to make sense with what our plan is the
bishop goes back to E3 but our structure
is a little bit more damaged and now the
Knight goes to E5 we've had to block
this bishop anyway so if we take at
least we can maybe take with this Pawn
Knight takes F
takes Queen goes to D2 this is a very
common idea against these fan cowed
setups to try and trade off the dark
squared bishop or the light squared
depending
excuse me and once it's gone then um
it's easier there's a lot of gaps in my
king safety and it's easier for white to
launch an attack the Knight goes back to
F6 the trading has been done Rook F to
B1 which is saying maybe white wants to
push this Pawn at some point to fight
against C5 there's already a lot of
pressure here Knight to
H5 and King to H2 this is maybe a little
bit uh trying be preventative maybe a
little unnecessarily so Knight to F4
jumping in Bishop goes to F1 to add some
defense to these squares the Knight is
eyeing up and queen to H4 and I'm
realizing okay this is another really
interesting game where it looked like we
wanted to fight on the queen side and I
think what's key here is sometimes it
can be easy to lose sight of some of
these things is it's not that we should
be attacking on the king side but if
white chooses to deny Our Queen side
push with moves like A4 and Knight C3
and this bishop then what else can we do
well we have some ideas of maybe putting
some attacking pressure right our Bishop
here is really annoying the Knight
moving in we can maybe make switch up to
a King side attack this is another good
thing to know the game continued F3 and
really beautiful Knight takes H3 because
now after the pawn takes Rook takes F3
and everything is invading it is very
hard to defend the queen went to E1
trying to force a trade but Rook takes
H3 sacrificing The
Rook for an
invasion white now or black now has two
threats Bishop to F3 threatening a lot
of different checkmating ideas uh and
Rook to f8 just sliding over to cut off
the king and add checks and even though
we've sacked some material it's very
hard to stop the game continued Knight
to D1 Bishop to F3 threatening Checkmate
and some other checks the queen goes to
D2 defending Rook to f8 and white
resigned here but just one sample line
of how the attack could continue was if
white if white tries to defend with
Queen to H2 then check King to F1 takes
the Knight with check now black is just
up material and the king is still on the
Run Queen takes E4 if you take my Bishop
I will take yours Rook takes Queen takes
Queen blocks on E2 we wouldn't mind a
trade here cuz we're ahead but there's
other ways to win Queen to G3 and
pinning the queen to the king and we
could go on from here but this seems
sufficient what are the things we've
learned from this game well uh I learned
mainly that in these types of positions
one thing we can choose to do is if we
can't fight on the queen side with our
normal push is to to potentially fight
for E5 and to do so in a way that we can
take back the way we want right we would
love our Bishop to recapture and keep
all those lines open rather than taking
with a pawn and blocking it off cuz even
though there was a beautiful attack in
the end of this game notice that this
bishop didn't really have anything to do
with all of it it was fully bled off so
if that can be avoided that's
ideal okay now I want to end with my
final recommendation right you've looked
at some videos you've talked to some
friends you've read some books uh you've
done some research well that's great
But ultimately the whole point of this
is to learn a new opening so you can
play it so what I did and what I
recommend and this actually works a lot
better if you're doing a few different
openings is to play some games online or
in person but especially online uh and
play a Time control that's faster than
what you're used to so play like if
you're used to playing 15minute games
maybe drop it down to 10 or even five
minutes what's the reason for that
normally I advise my students to play
longer games um because I want them to
work on on you know thinking and
spending time and really understanding
the positions but when you're trying to
study an opening if you have to Blitz
out your moves much faster than you're
used to it forces you to test whether or
not you actually know the ideas and kind
of are feeling the sense of the opening
or if you don't really get it at all and
you need to go back and do some more
research um the problem is if you've
done what I did which is just have one
open you want to study then you're going
to have a lot of games you play that
your opponent does not help you out so I
played about a dozen games on uh on I
think chess.com where or maybe two dozen
where you know half the time I was white
and so I just have to play something
else and then most of the time when I'm
black my opponent plays Pawn to E4 CU
again I'm playing faster times and
that's what happens most of the time so
I very rarely got what I wanted to try
but after about two dozen games I had an
opponent very kindly help me out in a
very strange way every every move I was
blitzing out C5 because this was the
whole point of the lecture and my
opponent starts with Knight to F3 and
I'm so
sad but then they play D4 so maybe I
have a chance I go Knight to F6 they
push past E6 C4 we're back in book this
is back to the game now Knight F3 is may
be a little strange they might sometimes
wait for that a little more but I'm back
to like this opening this is what I've
been studying and so now I'm excited and
I'm thinking okay let's remember so I I
want to take this Pawn so I took they
took back D6 right we don't want to let
them push too far when we're not ready
for it at a bad time and we want to keep
our Pawn on C5 safe Knight to C3 and
from here I'm like okay wait what do I
do what do I do oh I should fetto right
I want to control these dark squares so
so far I feel like I'm doing well E4 and
now we're actually like fully back in
book right this is like just a real
chess position
um Bishop to G7 Bishop to G5 this is
still theoretical um again a lot of the
people here played something like Bishop
B2 because they didn't want the Knight
to get traded um and I castled the move
the computer really likes here and some
of the Masters is to play H6 kicking
this bishop so something like uh H6 and
the bishop drops back and you can kind
of just Chase it down and attack it this
is something I kind of saw and the idea
is we're removing this piece from
control of the dark squares and our
Bishop is getting so much better cuz
it's got something this thing can't
fight against us so that's kind of one
of the ideas I learned in retrospect I
just
castled uh Bishop E2 now and again if I
play Bishop G4 here white has this idea
of switching sides so maybe another
opportunity to play that and I played
Knight B to D7 and this is the first
move that I really went off track I went
way off the database right because
remember um what what what the opening
ideas here well I probably should maybe
I can play for A6 and B5 um maybe I can
still bring the bishop out to G4 and see
if my opponent doesn't know this idea
because if I can trade for this Knight
that's still really helpful um the
problem with this move is I was kind of
combining some of the games in my memory
I was thinking well wait a minute wasn't
there that game where he went to E5 um
well the problem is he did that only
after he had to probably first I ought
to go for this idea and if my opponent
shuts me down with A4 then I say okay
not no need to worry maybe even better I
start with Knight to A6 because if I
play Pawn to A6 I notice I've kind of
move orded myself into a tricky
situation where now my knight can't
actually defend this square right it
can't go to A6 anymore if I start with
the Knight and bounce it over then I can
play A6 after and I have more Defenders
on this square but so maybe that's
something I can can work on with this
opening but I went Knight to D7
uh
here castles was played and now I played
A6 so I'm still going for that idea but
after A4 it's kind of tough to go for
this right I can't do it right away
because of the same thing we saw at the
very beginning there's this weird pin
situation between these Rooks and if
takes then I can't actually take back or
I'm going to lose my
Rook um it's also just even if I was
it's just not defended enough right it's
attacked three times and only defended
the once
so maybe I should have moved with the
Knight first but even still maybe this
just wasn't the right
idea uh I played Rook to B8 I think I'm
still being thematic with the plans the
computer doesn't love this move because
it's maybe a little too slow I still
probably should be fighting against this
bishop and trying to improve my own um
but I'm still I think working on uh
following the basic ideas here white
plays a serious blunder
B3 to me this looks like a normal move
at first glance I'm just maybe stopping
me from ever pushing forward but the
problem is again notice these dark
squares are all so weak now my Bishop is
just a monster this is something that I
totally missed while I was playing this
because again it was a faster time
control and my first time really playing
a game with this opening but that's
something really good to know is oh I
should really be paying attention to the
squares right these pawns are all
focused on light squares and now this
bishop is just seeing
everything and I got a little stubborn
here because I was like okay well I
defended this B5 push a little I wish my
knight had gone to A6 first because then
it would be easier um but I need an
extra defender on this square and so I
thought well let's do the queen this is
something I do all the time right the C
Pawn is moved let's get the queen in the
game the problem is the same as with the
Rook right now as soon as I push and
white takes my queen gets hit by The
Rook so this is you know some opening in
experience and again I learned a lot of
this through you know not while I was
playing it um some of it I did but a lot
as well through analysis after the fact
I went over the game and looked at the
computer and looked at the databases and
said what am I doing well what am I not
the problem here is yeah I just can't
really even though I'm defending yet I
can't push this
pawn queen to C2 defending the Knight
and I realized okay this was a misplay
my queen doesn't actually belong here um
I should pull it back and so I went back
to C7
it it's you know sometimes you know a
bit humiliating to play a move and then
immediately retreat but it's important
to recognize when you've made a mistake
and not just let it sit there and get in
your own way so I'm back to C7 opponent
played Bishop to F4 uh recognizing the
pin is no longer working I think the
bishop was fine there but um this is
still a nice diagonal to fight for and
to fight against this Pawn right
remember white really wants to do this
idea of putting pressure on D6 so this
seems a good way to do it it and I
played Knight to E5 and again the
problem here well I was too early right
I should let the bishop be defending
this Knight not the pawn because I don't
want to cut it off um white should just
trade here whether with the Knight or
the bishop I'm not sure and let me force
a pawn in my own
way uh instead white doesn't recognize
that and just Retreats the bishop and I
can move this Knight out of the way and
kind of defend everything and now after
takes takes I'm actually doing fine F4 I
drop my knight back to D7 but we see a
lot of the same kind of similar
attacking ideas even if they're not
executed as well from either side Knight
to D1 um just kind of rerouting the
Knight we'll talk about that in a second
uh B5 the Knight is not defending the
square so I push forward Pawn takes Pawn
takes E5 striking forward in the center
I took opponent takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes
lots of Trades Queen goes to C3 uh
offering me a free Bishop I decline cuz
we're playing a bullet game and I have
maybe 10 seconds and I I don't see it um
but we reach this position I play Knight
F6 again very low on time uh just losing
a
pawn uh and after this position is
reached I run out of time why has 25
seconds left on the clock but the point
wasn't to win this game remember the
reason I'm playing a fast time control
is so I can get experience with this
opening and I think I did I learned a
whole bunch from losing this game I
learned really I learned a few things I
learned that this plan of A6 and you
know B5 Rook B8 can be a little slow I
need to be aware of how much A4 stops
this plan I learned about the move order
maybe I should have put the Knight here
first so it's not kind of clogging
everything up I was reminded of how uh I
shouldn't just move my queen out on this
Diagon because it's an option because
it's now in my own way right this Rook
is going to attack
it I learned not to put my knight just
in the center because it's you know it's
going to get traded away and my Pawn is
going to block my beautiful Bishop which
later on some of you might have caught
this but I didn't was after Knight to D1
my beautiful beautiful Bishop is just
ready to take that rook and I was the
reason I found this was because the
computer said you're playing a fine game
and then this move blunder blunder
blunder blunder because there was a rook
that could have been taken or saved um
so you know that happens but the point
is playing this game really taught me a
lot about the opening that I wouldn't
have gotten just from reading right the
information the resources the videos
help me get the basics of it but then I
had to figure out how do I apply this
and I'm only going to know what did I
learn and what did I miss when I play it
and test it out so that's my
recommendation to you find some of those
really good resources learn the basic
plans and goals of the opening look at
some master games look at videos and
have people explain the ideas to you and
then just play some games and give it a
shot uh it can take a little bit of time
and practice and you know you might not
do it quite as well as me if you're not
as strong a player just naturally or
don't have as much experience and that's
okay don't try and compare um just pick
and open anything sounds fun and see
what you can do with it that is all the
time we have tonight but thank you for
sticking with me for beginning breakdown
hope this has been helpful and please
stick around as our Grandmaster in
Residence Victor mki will be teaching
right after this so thank you so much
have a great rest of your
[Music]
day